i gotta watch
him bust a nut in your old baseball
coach
[Music]
what's up guys i'm brendan chob go watch
my new commie special on think boy
youtube the gringo poppy available right
now for your enjoyment this is me
answering the internet
when you're drunk is it better to get
laid or have the ideal drunk meal
get laid because you're not going to
remember either but at least you know
you could have some fun also on the meal
i'm a thick kid at heart dude so when i
have a meal it's going to get out of
hand it gets pretty sloppy so there's a
good chance if i'm drunk i'm going to
[ __ ] my pants and i have to deal with
that in the morning
they both might stick with you for a
longer time i feel like the carbs are a
better one than ever a little bit of fat
versus a little bit of std i'd rather
who's
who is the worst group of fans
oh they all can be pretty mean to your
boy
uh
there's there's nothing worse than a
salty comic who didn't make it
especially with on the internet because
they they're comics so they'll be pretty
witty at writing so the the burns are
gonna hurt it's gonna be creative
like i'll you know you're you're fat or
you're stupid right whatever dude but
the comic will really rosham
you know and they're professional comics
but they just never made it and you're
doing pretty well there's nothing worse
than a salty comic who hasn't made it
and if you're a guy who's newer to
comedy they are beruto
[Laughter]
they will hurt your feelings and that's
why i want to talk to you about therapy
because it's helped me out man
you have a choice between a sum of money
and world peace
how much money would it take for you to
give up world peace world peace would be
lit man like you save ukraine i had to
get serious every save ukraine you got
all the [ __ ] in china
stuff going on here which isn't too bad
don't believe the media so uh
i turned to alex jones uh
oh listen i i wish i could come say
there's some money but world peace now
you kidding me dude
dude but think about i'm after a bit
hundred billion yeah after a billion
what are we after i'm good dude what are
we doing here's where the entrepreneur
comes into play here i saw world peace
you know how many sponsors i'm gonna get
i'm just talking about diet coke you
don't think diet coke's hanging off my
nuts after this
i'm on oprah i'm doing real [ __ ] man
dude think about it every city has a
statue of me who's hotter eeril or
jasmine jasmine dude ariel have fish
yeah right and also redhead would you
rather watch your oh my god would you
rather a watch your dad [ __ ] a hundred
year old man
or watch your mom kill someone it's so
dark i would rather watch my mom kill
someone because i'm gonna assume she's
killing them for a reason you know what
i'm saying my dad
my dad my dad's my hero are you gonna
watch
him bust a nut in your old baseball
coach
uh would you rather you have your
girlfriend's hair or she has your hair
oh dear kennedy jared leto's my spirit
animal i'd [ __ ] rather have her hair
she used to have pink hair do my me with
long pink hair bro we talked about on
the show harry styles be all over me
dude
and that's my goal man i'd be such a
dime piece as a gay dude i mean with my
blood ass these [ __ ] jeans i dress
like it i didn't know this
fits not cool in new york someone called
me the f word a [ __ ] third street man
i don't have it on now i wear a fanny
pack too okay someone called me the f
when's that the what
in public liberal new york i was like
wait what what did you say what did you
do
sorry
in cali i'm a solid nine
in new york i'm a four uh would you
rather have your internet history made
public or a sex tape that goes viral
well again the entrepreneur in me goes
if a sex tape because i got a dick on me
so if the sex yeah it's not bad dude uh
i mean it depends i don't know what we
deal with here man whether we got here
what are we doing i don't know i don't
know i don't know it's like we're
comparing banking to this competition
well i don't know it's big you've had
like trill owens through here and [ __ ] i
don't know like if i say something dude
that's not big area is 8 cool i don't
know dude i don't know cool i i don't i
don't know
we're talking about rap videos and [ __ ]
yeah thanks man
yeah you should have only fans i should
have only found you know how many [ __ ]
how much money you could make listen if
this special doesn't do well fellas
and you guys are doing your show and
you're like see shava's and only fans
no i'm at rock bottom
would you rather prematurely come in
your pants before sex or start crying
mid sex man i i gotta be honest fellas i
wish i could say i can bust another and
keep on keeping on but one and done man
i'm going to bed so if i nut my pants
i'm just passing out but i could use it
asleep the thing is with star crime mid
sex she might be like jesus christ and
then if you're crying you're like it's
the best i've ever had you know like
every time if you're single you get
spent but then eventually like three
weeks she's like dude you're just you
need to see a therapist you're crying
every [ __ ] time how many rats would
it take to overwhelm and kill you in a
fight pretending like a new york rat san
francisco rat and like a calabasas rat
it would be some hours because
eventually i'd be like
and then [ __ ] you know i have good
cardio so it's going to be a fight i'll
give myself i in my life is on the line
i would give myself around 24 hours yeah
i'm fighting i'm tired i'm sweating yeah
i'm biting heads off it's getting gnarly
would you rather spend the rest of your
life in a country music video or rap
music video well that's easy because
country music they're you know they're
like in the fields doing their [ __ ] it's
all white people in rap music listen
there's nothing better on this planet
than a fat ass let's be honest fellas
i'm on a yacht i got chains on undress
exactly how i am now i got cool sneakers
chains tats [ __ ] boats cars basically
are pretty [ __ ] close my life's
pretty much a rap video yeah but i'm
married with two kids one last
hypothetical for you before we wrap up
if you could have an endless supply of
anything what would it be easy no
brainer whistle pig whiskey the finest
rye whiskey in the game today distilled
in vermont
10-year 12-year 15-year 18-year or the
boss hog all of it incredible get yours
today at your local liquor store or go
to whistlepig whiskey.com all right big
shout out to the gringo poppy brandon
shop for his answer to the internet any
other comedians entertainers celebrities
that you want to see on the show drop a
comment below make sure you click the
bell so you get all the notifications
and make sure you subscribe